welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber the much talked about
Burn After Reading letter sent from
Roberta laundry to her son Brian has
been released after a judge determined
it could be included in a civil lawsuit
between the laundry family and the
family of the young woman that Brian
killed now this is the letter that
family members of Gabby Patito wanted to
see and while it contains multiple
intriguing sentences that are definitely
raising some eyebrows there's no
indication on it as to when it exactly
was written well right now we're going
to break down some of the biggest
revelations in that letter so Gabby
patito's parents are suing the laundries
and their family attorney for
intentional infliction of emotional
distress they claim that the trio hid
the fact that potato was dead and
instead released misleading statements
to the public Gabby Patito and Brian
laundry set off on a cross-country road
trip in July of 2021. two months later
laundry returned home from the trip
alone and potato's body was found on the
outskirts of a Wyoming national park the
next month laundries remains were found
in any park near his Florida home with a
journal confessing to the murder in a
hearing on Wednesday an attorney for Joe
Patito and Nicole Schmidt argued in
favor of releasing the Burn After
Reading letter the judge granted the
family access the letter Roberta laundry
wrote to her son Brian was in an
envelope with Burn After Reading written
written on it the judge said that the
letter could serve as evidence to prove
that the laundry's new potato was dead
when the letter was written although the
laundry's claimant was written well
before the road trip so let's break down
some of the biggest discoveries in this
short letter first up this line if
you're in jail I will bake a cake with a
file in it now of course this is pretty
damning since Brian laundry could have
been arrested for murder had he not died
by Suicide there's another line if you
need to dispose of a body I will show up
with a shovel and garbage bags Gabby
patito's body was found a few weeks
after she died from strangulation
according to why Wyoming coroner and
then there's this third line from the
letter which corroborates Roberta
laundry's statement that this letter was
a way for her just to try to connect
with her son as they went through a very
tough time in the relationship she wrote
quote no matter what we do or where we
go or what we say we will always love
each other joining me right now legal
analyst Brian buckmeyer Terry Austin you
guys have slightly different views on
this this letter so let's dive in Terry
you agreed that the letter should be
admitted into evidence why do you think
it's relevant it's completely relevant
it should be admitted because whether
this is literal or figurative or whether
this is code this letter should be
admitted and it made the right decision
and I think it's up to the jury to
determine what the date of that was
based on any forensic evidence it's up
to the jury to decide whether she was
being literal or figurative or somehow
using a code and so I think that the
judge has to determine is this
prejudicial or is it probative he made
the right decision it is definitely
probative you have to wonder what was in
the minds of the parents when they were
writing this and actually I do think
that the petite have a very good
argument that they knew where that body
was they knew that she was dead and that
they were hiding it in some way shape or
formed from the public and they were
trying to help their son do the same
thing well Brian it certainly seems like
a damning evidence against the laundries
but how would you argue otherwise if you
were their attorney two arguments here
at Jesse one it's only relevant if to
Terry's point if the letter happened
either before or when the parents knew
that Gabby batido was deceased they're
saying that that didn't happen the
timing makes it irrelevant the other
side is saying well we think it happened
at this time that's not a legal argument
that doesn't combat that also all the
points that you read out yeah those are
damning lines but she also says if you
fly to the moon I'll watch the skies for
your re-entry and if you hate my guts
I'll get new guts that's definitely a
hyperbole so what are we going to do
pick out some sentences that are true
and then say that other sentences are
hyperbole or just say in its entirety
this letter clearly appears to be
Hyperbole and not an actual true
statement of what she would do if we
only knew when that letter was written
it would clear up a lot of this
confusion there was another issue at
that hearing I want to talk to you about
and that was whether former laundry
family attorney Stephen bertolino would
be added to the civil suit attorneys
argued motions to dismiss the civil case
as well as motions to drop bertolino
from it the potato side contends that
bernalino made statements about wanting
Gabby to be found when he actually
already knew she was dead they said that
this was cruel the judge said that
she'll rule on the Motions to dismiss in
a written order over now to another
story that we're following closely The
Man convicted of shooting at a police
canine while trying to get away from
officers following a killing spree won't
face sentencing just yet K-9 Rigs and
some of his other four-legged colleagues
stood outside the courthouse waiting for
Alan Brown's sentencing hearing in
October of 2021 Wisconsin officers were
notified that brown was in a stolen
vehicle headed in their Direction he
suspected of two homicides out in
Chicago Kenosha police caught up with
him and he tried to run when Deputy
Terry Tift Unleashed canine rigs Brown
shot him in the head now fortunately
canine rigs survived with only a bruised
skull and actually returned to the force
Weeks Later Brown was found guilty of
multiple charges and was supposed to be
sentenced on Thursday but he refused to
come to the courtroom that's right after
a long delay the judge decided that
brown would appear via Zoom from his
cell but when the hearing started
Brown's lawyer informed the court that
brown wasn't taking his medication and
that his competency had been called into
question the judge then stopped the
hearing and said that they will have to
be dealt with before sentencing can
continue
and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody we have an update in last
month's deadly DUI crash in South
Carolina killing a bride on the night of
her wedding the victim's husband who was
injured in the crash is now suing the
driver and the places that sold her
alcohol Samantha Miller and Eric
Hutchinson were leaving their wedding
reception in a golf cart on South
Carolina's Folly Beach and that is when
police say Jamie Lee komorowski hit the
newlyweds newlyweds with her car killing
Miller Hutchinson was injured along with
other passengers in the golf cart
investigators say kamarowski a New
Jersey resident was going 40 miles over
the speed limit in a rental car and had
a blood alcohol level three times the
legal limit to drive kamarowski was
arrested for reckless homicide and
felony DUI Hutchinson Hutchinson was
able to leave the hospital but with two
broken legs as well as broken face bones
and other injuries now he's filing
wrongful death lawsuits against
komarowski and a number of local bars
and restaurants the lawsuit States quote
despite being noticeably and visibly
intoxicated at each of these
establishments kamarowski continued to
be served provided and or allowed to
consume additional alcohol in each of
them the groom is asking for funeral and
burial expenses in addition to actual
impunative damages a GoFundMe page has
raised more than 730 thousand dollars
for the victims in this crash
well this scenario might sound familiar
to our viewers as another wrongful death
lawsuit in South Carolina has made
headlines in the Alec Murdoch Saga the
family of 19 year old Mallory Beach is
taking the disgraced attorney in a
convenience store chain to civil court
in August Murdoch is currently serving
two life sentences for killing his wife
Maggie and Son Paul two years before
Paul was killed he was allegedly driving
drunk when he crashed a boat into a
bridge at high speed ejecting all five
passengers Mallory Beach died and
several other passengers were injured
the Peach family claims that Murdoch
along with Parker's kitchen are liable
for their daughter's death after Paul
used his older brother Buster's ID to
buy alcohol let's break it down so Brian
can all of the bars that komarowski went
to be held liable for what she did after
she left I think something extremely
difficult to be successful in that type
of argument and it's for this reason I
think that the last bar was probably the
most culpable the other bars because if
there is a duty at all for the
bartenders or people serving alcohol
it's to the person who observes uh
komorowski leaving intoxicated
intoxicated sorry all the other bars can
basically do the whole Spider-Man meme
point at each other so let's say for
argument's sake the three bars Heather's
Savannah and Kathy's if they if they
went to the bars in that order Heather
would point to Savannah's Savannahs
would appoint to Kathy and Kathy's bar
would probably be the liable one and I
think that's likely going to be the
argument that one bar may be more liable
than the others those are all our
producers that you name I'm not sure
they're going to be happy that you put
them as well in that order for a reason
yeah I get it uh but Terry so during a
call from jail with her father
kamarovski says that she hopes the judge
is going to go easy on her you think
that's going to happen I don't think
that's gonna happen first of all I do
agree with Brian I think that the bars
should be responsible particularly that
last bar because that person who served
or should have observed what condition
he was in but as far as her individual
liability is concerned I definitely
think even if she shows remorse even if
she takes responsibility even if she
talks to the judge the judge should
probably give her the maximum the DUI
she could get up to 15 years and for The
Reckless homicide she should get 10
years maybe he'll make it consecutive I
think 25 years is probably too much but
I do think she needs to learn her lesson
she spoke to her father and he told her
to suck it up and essentially she is
going to have to do some sort of time I
think for the public to think that
there's been some kind of Justice here
she killed one person seriously injured
another person she should pay some time
and basically ruined you know his life
it's really just a heartbreaking story
and when we come back another sad story
a woman is left paralyzed in New York
City after being pushed into the side of
a moving subway car up next we break
down why this one incident could be part
of an even bigger problem
[Music]
and we're finishing Today's Show with
another incident in the New York City
subway system a homeless man was charged
with attempted murder this week for
shoving a woman into the side of a
subway car leaving her paralyzed the
victim 35-year-old Amina yomas
immigrated to the United States from
Turkey in 2017. her art has been
published in magazines and Company
campaigns for Brands like Airbnb and
puma and around six Sunday morning
yomaso got off of a subway car at the
63rd Street and Lexington Avenue Station
headed to work authorities say the
suspect 39-year-old Kamal simroad pushed
her head into the side of the moving
subway car from behind according to
court documents yomas suffered severe
injuries including a cervical spine
fracture that left her paralyzed from
the neck down she's hospitalized in
critical condition simroad was arrested
and charged with second-degree attempted
murder on Tuesday after police
identified him on surveillance video his
next hearing is scheduled for Friday the
victim's husband released a state
statement following the attack and it
reads in part quote she is a person who
has strength who is resolved who is
determined and all of that was taken
from her it is crucial for the mayor to
recognize that prioritizing the Safety
and Security of the city's residence is
vital for their well-being and
prosperity this incident occurred around
6 a.m on her way to work in the heart of
Manhattan this underscores the pressing
need for improvement with the MTA we
must ensure the ability to safeguard
individuals including loved ones like my
wife
now there have been a string of
incidents in this past year that
highlights safety concerns on New York
City subway especially when it comes to
the city's homeless population so in
January of last year 40 year old
Asian-American Michelle go was killed at
the Times Square 42nd street and station
she was pushed from behind onto the path
of an uncommon oncoming subway train by
61 year old Marshall Simon this is a
homeless man with a history of mental
illness Simon turned himself into police
shortly after and he was charged with
second-degree murder he was eventually
deemed unfit to stand trial and was
permanently housed in a psychiatric
facility and earlier this month Marine
veteran Daniel Penny was charged with
second-degree manslaughter after choking
homeless man Jordan kneeling to death on
a subway car at the Broadway Lafayette
Street Station Penny plans to testify
before a grand jury next month and say
that he acted in self-defense against
the homeless man who also had a history
of mental illness Witnesses told police
that nearly began shouting on the subway
car about being hungry and not caring if
he returned to jail or even died but
those Witnesses say he was not acting
violently when Penny suddenly intervened
let's talk about this Terry can New York
City be held liable for injuries that
were caused by simroad well I think you
can certainly bring a civil complaint I
think it would be very difficult to
bring a criminal charge against the city
or the authorities or the police because
the Supreme Court has held that they
only have a duty for individuals who are
in their custody and obviously they
cannot prevent murders from happening
but from a civil perspective I do think
that there is a claim here we know about
all of these incidents because you just
named some of them Jesse so the city is
on notice that this is happening perhaps
they should have had more police on the
site perhaps they should have done
something as far as the MTA is concerned
built the subway in a different way I do
think that they could bring some claim
against the city for negligence and here
someone was severely injured so there is
this Duty and the duty was breached and
there was this harm and so whether or
not they Prevail I think you could bring
that claim you could make some arguments
and ultimately there might be a
settlement as far as the family is
concerned Brian can we talk about the
charges for a second attempted second
degree murder why not attempted second
degree manslaughter how is what penny
did any different than what cimrod did
so arguments can be made that Penny
could be charged with second degree
murder but he isn't and I think the LI
the the major reason for that is one
sentence depraved indifference to life
that's the major difference between the
second degree murder and second-degree
manslaughter could you say that Penny
strangling nearly passed the point of
him passing out as a Praying discipline
to that person's life absolutely but
from a legal standpoint I think it's a
lower level of depraved indifference
than I don't know pushing someone onto
the railroads of a of a train station in
the way that this person had and so
could both be charging murder yes but I
think they are properly charged with
what they are facing based on the level
of culpability and the mindset that they
have towards someone else's life no I I
agree with you and it's just horrible
that we have these two real life
examples and we're weighing it on a
legal sense because we shouldn't have
these examples that's the problem Brian
Terry thank you everyone out there
thanks for joining us here on Long crime
daily we're going to see you next time
as we discuss Justice in America
foreign